We have a
new report tonight
from the Dossier Center.
It's an investigative group
that tracks criminal activity
associated with the Kremlin.
It says that since
the start of the invasion, Vladimir
Putin has, for the most part, stopped
using his private airplane.
Now, this is his preferred mode
of transportation,
according to the dossier group,
which is run by Mikhail
Khodorkovsky, an opposition leader.
Putin is traveling
mostly in this armored train, equipped
with a special communication system.
The psychological reason
of using this train is that he's scared.
He's scared that he can be tracked, that
his plane can be tracked,
that his plane can be shot down.
He believes that it is a more secure way
to travel,
that nobody will know where he is going,
and nobody will understand that
he's inside history.